I guess when you grow up in La almost
everyone you knew became famous like you
grew up with Charlie Sheen right Tom
Cruz in that gr Robert D well Robert
Downey Jr Robert in my high in my junior
high high high school is Downey uh
Charlie Sheen Amelia estas Shawn Penn
Chris Penn Holly Robinson Pete uh it was
I it was just a weird time I think a
time in place for people I think they
just came out of that moment when you
were growing up with those people did
you think wow like this is an
exceptional
bunch of people or did they just seem
like everybody's goofball they just seem
like everybody's a goofball you
described that when you were growing up
with Charlie Sheena his father was
famous Martin Sheen right oh yeah and
you grew up around all these famous kids
but you weren't a wealthy kid well
Malibu in those days was populated by
you know teachers and firemen and and
and just you know regular people it was
way before the agents and Studio
Executives moved in you might get
somebody famous but they'd be like a
whacked out rock star who you like
wandering the highway were you jealous
of these kids who like like like being
friends with Charlie Sheen to me when
you're one of the poor friends that's
really tough I remember um Charlie for
his 16th birthday got a BMW car and I
was like wow we got a car for his
birthday and it was a brand new BMW and
that they always had hog andoss ice
cream right and I was like wow this is
it this is living and that's hard to
grow up around right I didn't I I had a
couple of friends who had wealth he had
a pool in the backyard and don't you
start to feel resentful like you're like
well I don't get handed any of these no
I went the other way with it that's the
thing I I I am was always really
aspirational and I and I was like oh got
it you can have hogendas oh got it you
can have pool and it just made me want
to work harder why did Charlie Sheen go
to school with a bulletproof vest was
that because his father was afraid that
he would get hurt or was it that Charlie
Sheen had a a delusional sort of you
know hard I I I just vividly remember I
don't remember the lead up but I Vivid
remember with our little lunch sacks on
the quad at Santa Monica High School and
and Charlie who was an early adopter of
both bulletproof vests and Polo
cologne um sitting there just sweating
but smelling great right and saying dude
it's just so hot I got this on today and
it was a bulletproof vest did you think
he was a wack TR or were you attracted
to him in the sense that like wow this
is just the greatest kid ever a greatest
kid ever without a doubt the greatest
kid ever but but I still am amazed by
people with charm lives which I consider
you one of like you were friends with
JFK Jr right when did you meet him I met
him at I think skiing in one year and
you became close friends right oh no I I
met yes that's right and he was great he
was a lovely lovely charismatic as we
all know guy I know people who know JFK
Jr and and and I know people who tell me
like in college that girls they he would
sit in a room and girls would take a
number and wait in line to meet him I
mean that's how [__] crazy like
basket Robbins but but but you can't
have a normal life with women anyway and
a social life when it when it's that
easy and I can imagine the two of you
parading around can you a man it must
have been like the Beatles walk in the
first in the first book I wrote I tell a
story about about that when I was young
and single and and sort of you know
wanting to party and find out what was
going on and and and I went up to JFK Jr
I said okay what's what's the plan
tonight and he was like I don't know man
we got to go find the girls and I was
just mean remember being a Gog and I
said to him dude you're JF K Jr you
don't have to go find any girls girls
will find get a clue I mean Mr Camelot
yeah he would go on a plane and women
would just throw themselves out yeah he
was he was really extraordinary and he
was the closest thing to royalty this
country's ever had right yeah he was and
then as where were you when you heard he
died later on as as luck would have it
um I found myself with a a pilot of a TV
show was sort of going to be hopefully
one of my comebacks I hadn't been on the
cover of a major magazine in over a
decade wow and JFK Jr put me on the
cover of George magazine for the
westwing before the show had ever even
aired and it was the last cover he made
before he
died